what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some really big news
about the Thunderbolts and Stephen young
and we also have some hints I believe at
Marvel studios's new Wolverine in the
MCU not Hugh Jackman's but a new one
which of course we'll talk about in this
video if you haven't heard the news over
the past week Steven Yeun has been cast
for a role in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe specifically in the upcoming
Thunderbolts film many people know
Steven Young from The Walking Dead and
Invincible now there was a lot of talk
about who he could be playing in the
Thunderbolts and since it was kind of
about super soldier serum and hulks
leading into Captain America 4 New World
Order I thought that he might be playing
a sort of older version of Amadeus Cho a
version of the Hulk after all both the
character and the actor are
korean-american however we have some new
reports today talking about who he could
be playing and I honestly am kind of
really digging it according to some
recent reports he is actually going to
be playing Century the golden man the
man with the power of a million
exploding Sons now we have several
reports today about this which of course
we are going to go over as well as talk
about what the story arc and what
Century's role is going to be in the
Thunderbolts film and how this will lead
into the events of Captain America 4.
and speaking of Captain America 4
Anthony Mackey has recently opened up
about how Marvel Studios is trying to
prevent spoilers even more than before
so we'll talk about that as well because
it's actually very interesting but first
let's start off by the first report that
came out yesterday and that was from
Grace Randolph in a tweet she said well
well well and she did the Emoji with its
mind being blown it seems the MCU has a
lot of faith in Steven Yeun after all he
is not Amadeus Cho hashtag Thunderbolts
hashtag Marvel so right away people
already thought okay well maybe he is
going to be playing century and she
followed up this tweet with another
tweet that said
um there were only two choices my dudes
with a gif that says think about it
heavily implying that he is going to be
playing Century however more reports
soon followed an hour later a report
from can we get some toast The Insider
account says so it looks like it's not
an if replying to a previous tweet that
they posted saying if Stephen young is
Century I hope his hair stays black and
turns blonde when he Powers up our first
live-action Super Saiyan could be him
which yes I totally agree I would love
for this to happen but that is what they
are replying to stating so it looks like
it's not an if now I really want a Super
Saiyan power up sequence for him
confirming he is indeed going to be
playing Century The Insider account my
time to shine hello who has a great
track record with these Scoops has also
retweeted what can we get some toast has
said further backing up the report but
that is not all for the reports the
illuminari has also reported that
Stephen young is going to be playing
Century in a report on their website
they State the rumor about the
Thunderbolt story is that Contessa
Valentina Allegra de fontaine's team
will be facing a Superman level threat a
threat despite being the founder of the
Thunderbolts she will have a part in
creating she's essentially creating this
team to cover up or fix her mistake the
mistake was the creation of Marvel's
Golden man a near Unstoppable Force the
Sentry the century according to our
sources will be portrayed by the
incredible Stephen young now Marvel has
not commented on this at the time I've
even reached out myself but these
sources do have really good track
records so we probably are looking at
our Century here with Steven young and I
think it's a great idea especially if
you check him out in this picture right
here this is fan art as Steven young as
century and I do think he looks really
really awesome and credit to the account
21x4 for creating this now like I
mentioned we do know a little bit about
the plot of the Thunderbolts and we also
know that this movie is going going to
go into Captain America New World Order
with the primary focus being the
government creating super soldiers and
what we'll call enhanced individuals
because like I mentioned in the
beginning of the video I personally
believe that Valentina Allegra de
Fontaine could be responsible for
creating Project X and possibly bringing
us Wolverine our new Wolverine into the
MCU not Hugh Jackman's of course we know
he's coming with Deadpool but a lot of
connections are now starting to be made
with this movie and with Captain America
new world order so there's two very
important things about the plot of the
Thunderbolts that I believe tie into
Wolverine one is the rumor that the
Thunderbolts team is going to visit
tayamat this is the celestial that got
killed by Cersei in the eternals well at
least as far as we know taimut is dead
but according to some previous reports
the Thunderbolts are going to go to what
is called tayamat Island in search of
adamentium most people know that name it
is what the metal inside of Wolverine is
made of the metal and side is adamantium
and apparently taimut island has
adamantium now whether that's the
celestial actually being made out of
adamantium itself or only being a part
of the celestial we are unsure yet
however what we have heard is that the
Thunderbolts team is going to the island
to collect it now of course that makes
you wonder why exactly are they
collecting adamantium well the first
thought in everybody's mind of course is
Wolverine when you hear adamentium you
think Wolverine the metal that is
infused to his skeleton but we think
about it even more when we know that
Sentry is actually going to be in this
movie you see project Sentry was a
combination of Canada and the United
States getting together to form this
scientific research group that is trying
to recreate the super soldier serum so
basically it was influenced by Project X
eventually Robert Reynolds the name of
century would work his way into one of
the labs drink the century serum which
is basically the super soldier serum on
steroids like a lot of steroids and he
would gain the power of a million
exploding Suns basically turning him
into the Superman of the MCU now this is
what happens in the comics in the MCU it
could be quite different and they could
tie in Project X directly to project
Sentry after all we don't really know if
project Sentry is going to exist all we
know is that Valentina Allegra de
Fontaine is apparently going to create
Sentry and this very well could be a
part of a Project X Program and that
could be why she wants adamantium
because in her Project X Program she
could have a mutant that can heal Logan
she wants to put that adamantium inside
of his body because we know that going
into Captain America New World Order
there's going to be a pretty big story
about super soldier serum and apparently
we are going to be getting some more
versions of the Hulk the famous one
obviously being Red Hulk but I think a
good amount of the story is simply going
to be about enhanced individuals and the
government trying to create them it
could be a big deal about how the
government created since country and
he's now a big threat and they had to
take care of him of course I do believe
he is going to be a good guy eventually
because he is in the comics but he also
does come with the void which is bad and
is always attached to him so that'll
probably be the true problem in the
Thunderbolts the void that comes with
the Sentry but then moving into Captain
America New World Order it'll primarily
be about the government trying to have
their own superhero team one that they
can control because obviously we know
that Thunderbolt Ross is the one who
created this Covey Accords he wants to
control the Avengers now we know that in
the MCU that is no longer the case he
doesn't control The Avengers anymore and
if we know anything about Thunderbolt
Ross that is not cool with him he wants
to have his own team of super humans
that he can control to do his work and I
think that's where a lot of the story is
going to come in in Captain America New
World Order and the story about the
government Valentina creating Century a
new super soldier but really just a
Superman that's gonna tie heavily not
only into the future but also in the
next Captain America film and I'm hoping
fingers crossed that Project X is a
government organization that gets
introduced into the MCU in either the
Thunderbolts or Captain America new
world order but hey let me know your
thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below do you think we'll
see a hint at Project X and what do you
think about Steven young playing Century
in the MCU leave your thoughts and
theories down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news don't
forget to follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf